Cool. Hi. Thank super happy to be here.
This is way more people than I was
expecting. Um I'm also I'm also really
um shocked and delighted that uh the
organizers put a talk about statistical
evaluation of LLM's second on the
program. Um hopefully I won't
disappoint. So, okay. So, I'm Josh Saxs
and I'm going to be talking about um how
we evaluate uh autonomous systems for
cyber defense. Um,
okay. So, um, as of last Thursday, um,
I'm I I'm at a startup that some friends
and I co-founded. Um, before that, for
about four years, I was, um, I was tech
leading a lot of the AI security work at
Meta. So, I I worked with the teams that
are working on applying AI to the sort
of broad range of security problems at
Meta. I also worked on prompt injection
defense and defending um, defending AI
systems from from AI native attacks. um
ancient history, you know, I sort of
grew up in the hacker scene. Um okay, so
echoing the the last talk. Um so as a so
so I think probably we're all on the
same page that um it's going to become
much cheaper and much more easy to to do
sophisticated cyber attacks going
forwards, right? So um I think we can
expect in the next few years um that
attackers will go from manual laborers
to managers of of AI agents that are
doing attacks. Um this means that we
have a big problem on our hands, right?
So so there's many organizations that
have um very few IT security staff at
all. Um they're going to need autonomous
cyber defenders. And then there's larger
organizations also who I think are are
really vulnerable. Um I think anybody
who's worked in security has always felt
understaffed. Um, so we're going to need
to build we're going to need to get
comfortable um with um the kind of
proposition I'm suggesting on this
slide, right? So an AI system completely
autonomously making a dangerous decision
like uh quarantining a production server
because it looks compromised.
Um we're going to need to get
comfortable with AI systems um doing
jobs that we only entrusted uh to humans
in the past. Uh let's say there's some
critical insider threat alert. We're
going to need to trust an AI system when
it says just trust me, bro. Uh, I
investigated the alert. You don't have
to worry about it. Um, and then we're
ultimately going to have to get
comfortable with um really sensitive
actions, right? Like AI systems. Um,
like imagine a hospital now that has,
you know, two IT, you know, two IT
security workers who can't possibly um
cover the entire threat surface. Um,
that hospital will need to be on need to
be armed with um a team of AI agents,
right, that's able to do things like
quarantine the CTO's account when it
looks like uh when it looks like it's
compromised. patch a production
codebase, shut down and compromise
hosts. All that will have to have be um
uh we'll have to we'll have to be able
to trust agents to to take these kinds
of sensitive decisions autonomously. Um
and we have we have the additional
problem that um that to actually verify
that defensive autonomous systems work
um requires that we somehow make sense
of neural networks that have tens of
billions of parameters that we don't
fully understand. Right? So um you know
we have two options, right? One is to
one is mechanistic interpretability to
sort of stare into the weight matrices
of the neural networks and try to verify
that they'll um correctly shut down the
right production hosts um which may
which may crash prod um or or or really
the only real option is um to to
understand these systems statistically
and behaviorally.
Um and so evaluation is like the big
blocker I would say uh in in our field.
Um, and this applies to every area of
autonomy in in cyber security. So, it
applies to autonomous code remediation.
It applies to autonomous alert
management. So, investigating and
closing alerts, especially the most
critical alerts. Um, managing access
control, so making sure that we're
neither underpermissioned or
overpermissioned in a large
organization. Um, cloud posture
management, probably the list goes goes
on here. Um, so we have a problem. So,
we're a field in which we haven't taken
evaluation all that seriously, I would
say. Um and we're going to need to
transition into becoming a field in
which um we take it very seriously much
like autonomous driving for example
right so the majority of time or a
significant amount of time in autonomous
driving goes to verifying that the
systems are safe right and in in the
next few years we're going to have to
move into that kind of modality within
cyber security as well
okay um so I'm going to start with the
with the bad news um and then I want to
talk about the sort of possible
approaches to um evaluating autonomous
AI cyber defense systems.
Okay. So, so here's here's the here's
the bad news. Here's the current
situation. So, our um our current ground
truth is just way too noisy uh to
support the evaluations that we need.
So, in in in classical machine learning
for for folks here who have like sort of
classical machine learning backgrounds,
um you know, um our problem setting is
one in which we have a transparent
problem like we have an image and we
want to know is there a cat or dog in
this image, right? Um and we've
developed a there's a bunch of classical
sort of machine learning evaluation
metrics that we've imported into cyber
security uh that are sort of based on
that premise that the ground truth is
really transparent. So for so precision
recall fcore uh rock curves area under
rock area under precision recall all of
this assumes uh that we have access to
transparent labels and we're operating
in an environment um in which um the
truth is um of course in cyber security
this just isn't the case. uh that's not
the kind of discipline um that that we
are that's not the kind of domain in
which we're operating. Uh
with respect to program security um
an AI system may propose a patch to a
critical program. Um how do we know if
the patch works right all we really have
you know we're up against sort of
theoretical computer science problems
like the halting problem and and and
knowing whether it works and so so
really we're using sort of heristics to
to decide whether or not the patch works
like passes the unit tests this sort of
thing. um like what's malware, you know,
and is a program malware, right? We're
up against these same kind of
theoretical problems and also more sort
of ontological and epistemological
problems of like, you know, the fact
that many binaries are actually dual
use. Um
and um okay, so um actually, so in my
experience actually building um
autonomous systems for AI security, I've
I've come up against this problem in
many practical settings. So for example,
um has anybody here actually tried to
get ground truth and train a system to
um follow up on alerts in a sock?
Probably a few. So I I've spent a lot of
time on this problem. Um so so when when
you go and try to alert um uh AI
investigation of of sock alerts and try
to actually get ground truth on which
alerts were actually worth investigating
and which were false positives, uh
you'll find that there's like a
doubledigit disagreement rate uh between
sock analysts, right? So, if you're
trying to label a sock alert cat, like
in in the fashion of cat versus dog, um
you're going to see a ton of noise in
those labels.
Um if you're trying to build a system
that automates access management, um and
you want to know um who should really
have access to that sensitive database
table that has user messages in it, for
example, um you'll find that access
investigators will disagree at a double-
digit rate, right, with respect to who
should actually access what. So, if
you're trying to train a machine
learning system or evaluate its ability
to automatically grant or deny access,
um you're dealing with a ton of noise in
your labels, which makes the evaluation
problem very different than the problem
of evaluating a computer system uh
computer vision system that decides cat
versus dog.
Um so, I actually ran a little
simulation for you guys uh to sort of
try to demonstrate this this concept.
Um, so if you so, so you should you
should sort of track me down after this
and I can tell you all the parameters of
the simulation, but basically if you add
like a 1% flip rate where you're
flipping true positive to false positive
and false positive to true positive in
your labeled data with which you're
using to evaluate your machine learning
system, um, your ability to measure
whether or not your system actually
works just plummets as you as you add
noise. Um so so in this simulation I'm
imagining you have like a sort of
perfect AI system uh that predicts for
example whether or not a sock alert is a
false positive. Um and as we add noise
from you know.5% of the labels flipping
to 3% of the label flipping um what we
observe is that it so the system starts
to look really inaccurate um and we sort
of start to hit a noise ceiling around
around above which we can't actually
measure the system's ability to improve.
Um, and I guess I would say overall that
the sort of bad news here is that all of
this uncertainty is just built into the
environment when you're when you're when
you're trying to build autonomous cyber
defense systems. Um, so there these
theoretical computer science problems
like like the halting problem and state
space explosion that makes it impossible
to know whether or not a program is
bug-free or whether or not a patch is
going to crash prod. Um, there are these
sort of societal problems of of of
people disagreeing about about whether
or not a binary is really malicious or
not given many binaries are dual use.
Um, and we're not going to we're not
going to solve these problems um through
more effort. We're always going to be
operating in this very uncertain
environment which um which begs the
question, how are we going to ship
systems that we can rely on uh which we
can convince leaders of, which we can
convince policy makers of uh that can
actually manage the cyber security of
organizations autonomously.
Okay. Um so I think the good news is
that I think that our framing has been
really wrong in how we evaluate um
autonomous cyber defense systems.
Okay. So I don't know how many sort of
classical ML people there are in the
background but anybody who studied ML in
college or has done a lot of machine
learning is familiar with this concept
of the oracle. Right. So this is the so
I actually brought in a picture a real
life picture of the oracle here. Um, so
she so she sits there somewhere in the
Mediterranean, right? And she's like
she's like presented with objects and
she labels them and those labels are
true, right? So um you know on the left
she's um
uh she's she's labeling images as cat or
airplane or banana. Um but um her
process totally breaks down when when
when we present her with these cyber
security artifacts. [clears throat]
Um but you know today when we measure
the precision recall fcore rock curve of
a of a of a security machine learning
classifier we're assuming we have an
oracle right so so this is the sort of
evaluation model that we're using in
evaluation autonomous evaluating cyber
autonomous defense systems right now. So
we we have sort of the ML system which
could be an AI agent. It's just a black
box. We're not we're not concerned about
what's in the box and and and what it's
doing is it's saying whether a security
alert is a true positive or false
positive. So it it outputs just a series
of ones and zeros, right? So we sort of
reduced its behavior to the to this
series of ones and zeros. And then we
have a set of labels. Now the labels are
actually totally noisy and we can't
trust them, right? The labels are like,
you know, one one sock analyst who had a
bad lunch, right, has decided that this
this this this alert was not
investigation worthy, right? Um so it's
actually really noisy, but we assume
that they are not noisy, right? Right.
And then we can compute a bunch of
summary statistics um which none of us
actually trust very well in the field
and and then and then we use those to
present to our leadership and decide
whether that system is worth deploying.
Um so imagine how upset you'd be if you
were an AI agent that has just generated
100,000 tokens of thinking and tool
calling and explanation of its behavior
and information retrieval uh to finally
produced a well explain explained
decision about whether a sock alert was
a false positive or true positive. and
you reduced all that complexity and
reasoning down to a single bit of of
error information, right? Um so that's
actually what we're often doing when we
when we talk about evaluation of
autonomous cyber defense systems. We're
sort of reducing all that complexity
down [music] um to a single bit of
information which we don't actually like
which we don't actually have a good
label for. Imagine if we hired security
engineers uh on the basis of these kinds
of binary multiple choice tests and
never never um interrogated their actual
ability to reason under under
uncertainty. That's sort of what we're
doing with with AI systems. At least
that's the sort of lingua frank in terms
of how we talk about evaluation in our
field.
Okay. So here's the thesis of my talk.
So I think these classical metrics that
we typically use um I think they're
important. I think we need them. I think
we need to we need to acknowledge and
sort of bake in how noisy they are in in
how we evaluate our ML systems. Um but
then I also think we need to really lean
in to understanding how our agents are
reasoning and behaving and evaluating
that also as they make decisions. Um I
think I think I think our mental model
should be that that when we hire a
security engineer, we're hiring them to
make good well- validated decisions
under the extreme uncertainty of our
fields. And when we hire an AI agent,
we're assessing their ability to do the
same.
Okay. So, here's how um in my own work,
I've um operationalized this. Um I'd
love to hear feedback after this talk
just to hear if other folks are thinking
in the same in in in the same direction.
Okay. So, so we need to evaluate our
agents as we move to deploy them
autonomously as we would humans um who
are deciding under uncertainty. Um, so
we need to ask questions like how high
quality are is the agent's reasoning
process under complex ambiguous
circumstances. Did the agent come to the
same conclusions as our as our best
security engineers in the last 10
incidents? And if not, why not? And was
the agent actually right? And actually,
at least in my work, uh, many times we
find that agents are actually right
against human labelers.
Um, in a very practical and formal
sense, what this means is that we need
to define a kind of interview protocol,
uh, like a like a rubric for our agents.
we need we need to define what good
looks like not just in terms of the
outcome but in terms of the process that
they're taking to solve the highly
ambiguous problems that we're going to
need our agents to solve. So for
example, did they did they you know
let's say we're looking at agents uh in
in an access management setting and
we're asking did did they correctly
grant access uh you know to a contractor
uh you know with respect to a database
table containing millions of user
messages. Um we don't just want to ask
did they make the right decision. We
also want to ask did they gather the
right evidence? Did they reason
correctly from first principles about
that evidence? Did they justify their
decisions when explaining their
decisions correctly? Uh did they explain
clearly? Um much like we'd be
interviewing a human. Um and and then we
want to then we want to grade th those
agent trajectories at scale u based on
the rubric and a very well- definfined
rubric protocol. Um and then because
that doesn't scale, we we need to train
um an AI system to actually automate
that process of reviewing agent
trajectories. Um and then once we
deploy, we need to monitor um and see if
the agent has gone off the rails. Um so
here here's sort of a worked example of
applying this to an access management
system uh that monitors uh granting
access to sensitive resources within a
company. Um we look at some at at
criteria like evidence gathering policy
understanding first principles uh
reasoning um whether the agent is is
sort of outputting logs in an audit
auditable way and decision and but also
finally decision accuracy also but we
but it's a sort of whole but basically
you know what I'm arguing here is that
we need a much more holistic approach
than just looking at these summary
statistics.
Um you don't need a whole lot of samples
to to calibrate an LLM judge uh to to do
this sort of holistic rubric based
analysis. Um, often time I mean I don't
have time to go into the details of the
statistical model I'm using here, but
oftentimes a 100 samples is enough to
get you started. Um, and once you once
you have um the ability to judge uh an
AI agent's ability to reason and decide
under uncertainty um at scale um then it
gives then it gives your team um a sort
of hill to climb in terms of improving
an agent to the point at which you can
deploy it. Um so so typically the
process that I've found works is like
you define some bar um above which we'll
deploy an agent uh that takes all these
holistic dimensions into account. Um and
then the team sort of hill climbs all of
these criteria until we get above a bar
and actually deploy the agent and and
and sort of align that it's safe to
deploy. Um and then once it's deployed
you sort of monitor it and make sure
it's at steady state.
Um, so I think like I just want to
emphasize at least at least in my work
this kind of approach has really
unblocked a lot of progress. Um, so you
know you could be in this kind of
dystopian world uh on on the left uh
where you're just looking at accuracy,
precision, recall and fcore. Um, and
then when people sort of stare into
these statistics they sort of get into
disagreement about whether well is it
the model that's wrong or are the labels
wrong? The labels are really noisy which
is basically always the case. or you
could be in this different world, right,
where you're looking at many different
dimensions at once. All of which are
somewhat noisy, but together give you a
much more complete picture of whether
your system is actually working.
So, I've got three more minutes, so I'm
just going to go pretty quickly through
the last few slides. Just some practical
um notes about process. So, um it should
probably be obvious at this point this,
but I believe this, but like you know,
there's many like there's many teams
right now in AI security that are
operating with no no eval. Um this is
this is a real dystopia, right? because
then it's just all vibes. It's all
engineers, you know, tweaking their
agents and saying it works on their
machine. Um, and it's very hard to ship
if you have any level of rigor, right?
So, it's much better to have an eval
program. Um, and treat it as iterative.
You're going to learn a lot as you start
to evaluate your agents. Um, and you
want to keep your leadership aligned
with um, with the way you're evaluating.
Um, and that makes it very easy to ship
because once you're above your
deployment bar that you've sort of
aligned with leadership, you can
actually ship the agent and monitor it
monitor its behavior in production.
Um this creates a lot of time. I would
say it takes it takes at least 50% of a
team's time to to do evaluation but you
actually move like 10 times faster.
Um last thing I'll say which would be a
whole separate talk is that um
we both um at the startup where I am but
also at meta you know have done some
really interesting experimentation
around automatically optimizing agent
architectures using using coding coding
tools and prompt and genetic genetic
algorithms that do prompt optimization.
Once you have a really good evaluation,
you can actually use AI coding tools and
um LLMs to actually hill climb all of
those metrics um while also being
careful of overfitting.
Okay, just summing up. Um
okay, so we're we're under time pressure
to to do this. I I think I think if you
look at the pace of progress over the
last couple years and extrapolate
forward um it it sounds science fiction
but it's quite reasonable to expect that
there will be armies of um artificially
general intelligent robots um scaling up
um adversarial activity against all of
our networks. um if we can't if if if we
can't deploy autonomous systems that can
make sensitive changes changes in our
infrastructure with confidence and
knowing they won't break stuff um we're
going to be in serious trouble and and
evaluation is in my mind um the main
hard problem there
um and just to restate my thesis um I
think we just need to move towards this
model in which we start treating agents
as decision makers uncertainty as
opposed to um as opposed to just just
relying in these sort of oracle based
statistics. Um, so I don't know if we
have time for questions, but uh, yeah,
thanks for having me and um, yeah, would
love to talk to people afterwards.
[applause]
>> We've got a couple minutes for
questions. Uh, we've got one in the back
right behind you, Matt.
So I here I wanted to ask you um have
you looked at improving your LLM judge
with negative uh judgments from the
humans like when the humans disagree
more with the judge? Has this worked
better for you or worse? I'm really
trying to save how many things I give to
the engineers to grade because their
time is very valuable. So uh so I'm
asking if you've had any study of the
negatives
working better on your judge
improvements.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We should I I think we
should probably talk after um but yeah I
mean basically my experience is I mean
so I think you need a fairly complicated
basian model in order to build in in
order to do this kind of calibration and
yeah it needs to take into account you
know you need to discount you know you
need to put sort of more uncertainty
around labels that you have more
disagreement about. is if you have a
committee of three reviewers and they
all disagree, you want to you want to
wait those if you have three reviewers
all agreeing strongly, you know, on um a
given dimension of your evaluation,
obviously those those get weighted more
highly, right, than cases where you have
more disagreement, which I think is what
you're saying. So, I think basically yes
is is my answer, but we should talk more
afterwards.
>> One more up front here. I'll I'll bring
I'll bring it to you.
Um, is there a material difference in
some of the evaluation methods out there
for models that are not in security
work?
>> Sorry, can can you add a little more?
Yeah, go ahead.
>> Yeah, so I'm familiar with evaluation
for AI models that apply for different
application set of data, right? Not for
security work.
So is can you apply those evaluation
methods here or do you have to do
materially different evaluation methods?
That's the question. I mean I think
basically
I think in terms of like the the
statistics that you use I think you I
think basically you just need to use
test textbook statistics but take this
multi-dimensional approach that I'm
describing where you're looking at the
agent's ability to reason gather the
right data you know um uh but I don't
think there's any novelty in the math
there but I think that um I think where
the domain expertise comes in is
understanding it's basically like where
you want domain expertise is like if
you're if you're deploying an autonomous
system that patches your code and a
human never looks at it. You want you
want a lot of domain experts designing
the evaluation like you want the same
level of expertise as you'd have in
terms of the people hiring your security
staff I would say. So you want deep
domain experts deciding what what the
criteria in your rubric are but the
actual statistics I think don't change.